our work evolves and over time it
becomes less careful less anal
less conscious and more a reflection
of the truth of our soul
what's the dna of a writer people are so
fascinating
i i don't know that i've ever met
someone who is not
possessed of the most surprising story
in life experience the only people who
don't know it is the person living that
story
they take them you know people take
themselves for granted they tell a
lesser version they have these sort of
they they they they don't see themselves
the way i see them or the way you might
see them
i think the dna of a writer is so
deeply anchored both in this life
experience ancestrally
in every sense um
there's a wonderful quote
by ben kingsley and i can't remember it
precisely but it's something like
our work evolves and over time it
becomes less careful less anal
less conscious and more a reflection
of the truth of our soul
and i think that's really the journey of
an artist
it's there but it needs to be freed it's
like carving the day of it or letting
off
wine mature and it's like as we grow
into what we do and we relax into it and
we have the confidence that we don't
have to
we're not thinking from the neck up so
much
we're finding the truth zone right
[Music]
i think we spend much of our life
mastering something
becoming really good at the craft
whatever that is whether it's a creative
pursuit or not
but then in time you just cross this
sort of invisible threshold
where it just you start taking deeper
cuts
you trust yourself
that's when it gets really interesting
what's the difference between writing as
a hobby and writing as a career
the difference between a hobby and a
career as a writer
it's a choice
and sometimes that choice is conscious
and sometimes it's not
there may be someone who you know who
who
is a hobbyist who's as serious
and and devoted and and possessed by the
act of writing as anyone else
they may lack the commitment to do what
it takes to make a career out of it
and there are a lot of people who think
it's a career but they haven't
you know like what's the measure of a
career
well the measure of a career would be
superficially
are you earning a living doing it but it
would also be are you really getting the
appreciation acknowledgement are you
forging the relationships with the
people who really
constitute that community in a
meaningful way
or are you an outlier and not an outlier
but are you
are you an outsider
who's really not knocking on those doors
um i think there are so many brilliant
stories that get lost to us that are
important
because people don't knock on the door
because they're
they're more content in the safety of it
being a hobby they may not refer to it
as the word hobby
but not really
and i think there are a lot of artists
who need champions
they need people they need a sherpa they
need a guide
you know one of my early heroes was max
perkins and max was
a man of letters he was a brilliant
writer himself but he was also
most of his adulthood and the single
best editor in my view of the
in the 20th century in america
and he was the father figure who
discovered
uh and nurtured and launched careers
for faulkner and hemingway and ring
lardner and thomas wolf and just the
list goes on
um and
a lot of these creatives either would
have
there are a lot of inside won't get into
particular stories but there
faulkner might easily have never come to
hollywood
he might never have had certain of his
books published had it not been for max
and the same probably is true in varying
degrees with certain of his other
illustrious
clients so i think it's sort of a
you know it's
it's hard to adjudicate at what point
people have the constitution to really
take it into their own hands and say
consciously i'm going to be disciplined
i'm going to find my way in
or i'm just going to be a soloist and
enjoy the active writing
and there's a lot of gray in between
those two
um i think the first thing is just to
recognize
the phenomenal joy if that's your
if that's true for you right like for me
i'm a natural writer i'm not an author
and i'm not a screenwriter i'm a writer
they're different i take enormous joy in
writing it's one of my happiest moments
of the day
but i don't see that i'm a professional
writer
i think my my my marketplace skills
are better uh i'm better as a producer
i'm better as a fire starter and a
facilitator and an organ
orchestrator than being
and i'm a very good editor but i don't
think i'm a screenwriter
so it's kind of knowing yourself and how
far you want to push it
and do you have the gumption to do so
if we were going to break down the day
of two screenwriters
so one who is quote waiting to be
discovered versus one who
as you say leverages their entertainment
career
what would those two days look like
oh gosh very different now they may have
equal levels of discipline or lack of
discipline when it comes to
how and when and where they write i mean
some writers it's like they're early
morning writers or their nighttime
writers or whatever
is their sort of biorhythm creatively
right uh and do they do that
consistently and do they black out a
certain number of hours and do they hang
the same
go on fishing sign on the door so the
family knows leave me alone
right um so those are all one
sort of one category of of um
discipline and decision that a creative
makes
one is self-response makes a decision to
be self-responsible
like it would be great to have an age
but it's not essential i'm still going
to make it
so i'm going to be intentional and i'm
going to allocate a certain amount of my
brain and my
my heart and my consciousness and my
time
to having a plan i'm going to build my
own plan i'm going to say i'm going to
dedicate
anywhere from 30 minutes a day to an
hour a day to two hours a day on my
career versus
the hours that i spend writing which is
about my craft
i'm going to have a vision a plan long
term
short term in the next month or you know
every month i want to make these kinds
of measurable steps forward
i wanted this to happen in six months
this to happen in 12 months
and you may or may not hit those marks
but the intention the entrepreneurial
sort of energy of yeah there's this
other
rail this other track that i'm going to
pay attention to
and and and respect as much as i respect
the greater amount of time that i spend
with the actual writing and it's kind of
be consistent
it's like an athlete when you're
training you know it's
you've got to be um
you've got you've got to be a bit
rigorous and say
you know what what do i need if i'm
going to succeed
you know if my manuscript or my
screenplay is not going to
show off its own head in their drawer
while it gathers dust what do i need
i need a team i need to know people i
need people to
uh collaborate with and i need people to
you know who are
but before i need them i want to have
the relationship with the people that
eventually i'm going to need
when i have a new project ready who are
those people
and then make it a point to
build out your i mean there's nothing
more important than just i i
i don't really love the word networking
but
that's what it is it's saying i need
i need my village i need my tribe i need
my team
whatever that looks like and i'm not
talking just about a representative i
mean
a real community of people that are my
my creative collab
so twitter going on twitter being a part
of
writer organizations whether they're on
social media or separate from social
media absolutely
where do i get immerse myself in that
conversation
so that i can get feedback so that i can
find resources i can share resources and
opportunities
and if i want to introduce someone to
someone else it'll be a generosity
that's well received and reciprocated
yeah put yourself in that flow when
you're not
in your writing space
i think it's and and not just and not
just
with other writers um i think it's
important
that you color outside the lines and
that you be a little bit imaginative and
daring
not just with your writing but in your
choice of
uh you know we've talked about this
before most writers
uh think in terms of agents or
producers either representation or who's
going to get my help
get my project produced and that's all
wonderful
but there are all these other people out
there that people aren't knocking on
their door
and they're available and they'd love to
talk to you and share their wisdom
so why aren't we reaching out to the
line producer the casting director the
et cinematographer et cetera there are
editors and other writers that you can
glean
inordinate wisdom from and have real fun
with
so i think that you know it doesn't
always have to be specific
you know like a specific result or goal
that you want to achieve it's just
saying
my greatest currency is really being a
part of this
community that is the filament and tv
enterprise
right i i need to walk the streets of my
community
and know my neighbors and be able to
talk to them
and be welcoming of them
and what if you're shy and maybe they're
not welcoming of you
i don't believe for a moment that
they're not welcoming
i do believe that a lot of people are
shy
and but that's you know being shy
is not an excuse not to succeed it's
just not
um it's hard but i've had i can't tell
you the number of people
that i've coached over time
who come back and go oh my god i had no
idea
this is like you know the red sea
parting i didn't know
it was so easy and so much fun to meet
people i thought it was scary
i thought there was a monster in the
closet i thought these were fire
breathing weapon
terrible terrible people who didn't want
to know me
and and and it's like oh my god i just
forced myself
and it was very uncomfortable it was
extremely awkward
i didn't like it but i forced myself to
do
for one week what you suggested and i'd
make two calls a day for a week
and by that friday it was like
oh my gosh there was one person who was
too busy
there was one person who had some
attitude
but eight people welcomed me
and i'm going to be speaking with most
all of them again in another week just
the way you taught
and it's it's it's i'm not taking credit
for it it's just like it's
it was just like a push go jump in the
water you're not gonna drown
flop your arms you're gonna swim may not
look beautiful the first time
but it it doesn't take long before it's
like oh you let your shoulders down and
say you know what
i can let go i can lay down the stories
that don't serve me
and a lot of people have that story that
oh i'm sure
is there two sides of the coin was i'm
too shy i'm introverted i'm not
comfortable
it's scary i don't want to do it
and the other side is they don't want me
to do it they're not friendly they're
not welcoming
i have or i have no value and nothing to
contribute to the conversation
like i'm subhuman and those stories are
just stories
they're not real but
we only learn by doing
that may be an exaggeration but i really
believe that doing is the way we learn
fastest and if you pick up the phone and
force you to do something that's really
not native to you that's really
actually quite audacious
and you do it a few times it's suddenly
it's like public speaking
everyone says publix more people fear
public speaking than death
were you afraid of your ted talk um
i i was always horrified of public
speaking
i actually enjoy it now
um the things that you worry about
uh no one else is worried about
it's crazy because we think we are the
universe but no
people are rooting for you we see that
all the time in performances whether
it's public speaking or
you know singing or whatever it might be
athletes you name it we want people to
win
if you just lay those stories down long
enough to take some action
you grow a new muscle very quickly it's
not terrifying
it's actually appreciated
and it's the fastest path to from a to b
you